-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome. Wow!
That is a crowd right there!
Oh, my goodness!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
I'm very excited about this.
John Cena and Henry Winkler
are my guests tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
In a little bit,
we'll hear what it's like
to hit someone
with a folding chair.
And we'll also talk to
John Cena.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to some news first.
Well, guys, last night Senate
Republicans used the filibuster
to block a major voting rights
bill called
the For the People Act.
Yep, Democrats wanted things
like automatic
voter registration
and Election Day
to be a national holiday,
while Republicans wanted
every polling place
to be at a yacht club.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. They blocked
the For the People Act.
Senate Republicans
haven't been this happy
since Kenny G
started touring again.
[ Laughter ]
You can tell a lot of
Republican Senators are ashamed
that they blocked
the voting rights bill
'cause now they're scared
to be seen in public.
In fact, some of them are
even using body doubles.
For example, Senator Ben Sasse
is using his body double,
SpongeBob.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's getting
that serious.
Next up,
here's Senator Roy Blunt.
His body double is
Jack Nicholson's Joker.
[ Laughter ]
He doesn't want
to be seen in public.
-Wow. That's crazy.
-Senator Roger Marshall
is using his body double,
a pack of Chiclets.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, they don't want to be --
-They don't want to be seen.
-Senator Rick Scott
is using his body double,
a human thumb.
[ Laughter ]
Just walking around.
-Wow. Oh, my gosh.
-Finally, of course,
Mitch McConnell
is using his body double,
Toby Turtle.
[ Laughter ]
It's just -- just to be safe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, listen to this.
I read that Ivanka Trump
and Jared Kushner
are trying to
distance themselves
from former president Trump
because they're tired of him
complaining about
losing the election.
When he heard that one of
his kids wanted distance,
Trump was like, "Please be Eric,
please be Eric."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is fun.
During his weekly address,
Pope Francis had a surprise
guest in the audience.
Watch this.
[ Laughter ]
Spider-Man.
Vatican security was like,
"Hey, I know we said everyone
should wear a mask, but this is
taking it to a whole new level."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the visit ended
when Spider-Man
kissed the Pope's ring
upside down.
-Oh.
-Kind of awesome.
[ Laughter ]
Well, Tinder rolled out
a new feature yesterday called
"Hot Takes," which lets singles
chat before matching.
And this is cool.
As an added bonus,
they're providing users
with a list of things
that you should avoid saying
during this introductory chat.
[ Laughter ]
For instance, things such as,
"Only three more days until
this ankle monitor comes off."
[ Laughter ]
Don't say that.
-Don't say it.
-Don't start with it,
at least, yeah.
Or how about this one?
"What do you know about
starting insurance fires?"
[ Laughter ]
-It's called Tinder.
-Yeah.
And finally, this one here,
"It's crazy,
but this is the only dating app
that hasn't banned me."
You shouldn't say those things
to open up.
[ Applause ]
Give it a little time.
Some more business news -- I saw
that budget airline Frontier
recently added
a COVID recovery charge
of $1.59 to passengers' tickets.
$1.59 might not
sound like a lot,
but on Frontier,
that's a round trip to Orlando.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Sam Adams
is offering to pay
$10,000 wedding bar tab
for couples who include
Sam Adams summer ale
in their wedding vows.
[ Laughter ]
This is great.
Half the grooms in Boston
already planned on saying it,
but now they might get paid.
[ Laughter ]
Not to be outdone, you can also
win 10% off the cocktail hour
if the priest yells "Hebrew
National pigs in a blanket."
I know a lot of people out there
that find math boring.
-Oh.
-Yeah, math.
Well, we've updated math
to make the equations
more about stuff
that you can relate to.
It's time for
"Popular Mathematics."
Here we go.
♪♪
♪ -Popular mathematics ♪
♪ Mathematics ♪
[ Laughter ]
-That's my favorite --
-I love that song.
-That's my favorite song.
♪♪
♪ -Popular mathematics ♪
♪ Mathematics ♪
-Do the robot.
[ Applause ]
-Unbelievable.
You guys are great.
Let's take a look at
our first equation here.
Fly swatting plus grunting
equals Wimbledon.
You see what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
So that's how it works.
So if you take
a high school graduation
plus the worst hangover
you've ever had,
it equals college graduation.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
How about this one?
If you take your day
minus two hours,
minus another two hours,
plus six random songs stuck
in your head for the next week,
it equals using TikTok.
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Two hours later.
-Here's another one.
Hard-shell tacos plus Uber Eats
equals soft-shell tacos.
[ Laughter ]
Doesn't really --
they don't travel well.
-Yeah, they don't travel well.
Sog-gy ta-co!
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
[ Laughter ]
-Just instinct. I've never done
that before in my life.
If you take a guy in Brooklyn
trying to get
someone's attention
plus a guy in New Jersey trying
to get someone's attention,
plus a mom,
it equals Yo-Yo Ma.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
"Yo."
-Here's another one.
Pop-Tarts plus doing a semester
abroad in Europe
equals Toaster Strudels.
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-And finally,
if you take Captain America
plus Iron Man
plus the Hulk plus IKEA,
it equals Avengers Assemble.
[ Laughter ]
That's all the time we have for
"Popular Mathematics."